- For as long as there's been crime,
there have been criminals
bragging about those crimes.
Smartphones record our daily lives,
and some of our daily lives
include a whole bunch of criming.
(TV static)
(beep)
Hey, what's up guys?
Welcome back to Illegal Eagle.
Today I stole 50k Bitcoin
and used it to hire a
hitman because it's fun.
This is why you should take
legal advice from a YouTuber.
Remember to like and subscribe
and always brag about your
crimes online and to the police.
(beep)
And I can't remember who said it,
but it's a strange coincidence
that as soon as we all had video cameras
in our own pockets 24/7,
ghosts disappeared,
aliens stopped visiting,
and police started
shooting unarmed people.
But while the phones may be smart,
the criminals are still really dumb,
so today we're gonna cover some
of those stunning instances
where criminals might just
have gotten away with it
if it weren't for those
meddling smartphones.
Now, selfies are not just
about making dumb faces
with a dream of gaining
Instagram influence.
Selfies also have helped bring
dumb criminals to justice.
Like 19 year old Albert Wilson,
who stole a phone, took a selfie,
and then tattled on himself
by accidentally emailing
his own photo to the victim.
And here's how it all went down.
One fateful Saturday night in 2013,
Albert Wilson and five accomplices
surrounded a 16 year old boy in the Bronx,
ordering the victim to empty his pockets.
Wilson proceeded to grab
the teen's Samsung
Galaxy S Epic smartphone
before fleeing with his fellow thieves.
But the mystery of who
stole the teen's phone
would not last very long because
shortly after the robbery,
Wilson could not help but
test the photographic quality
of the Samsung Galaxy
by snapping his selfie.
But honestly, that's not surprising.
Hey, Rene, how good was the
Samsung Galaxy S's camera?
- Well, Devin, Samsung is
actually the perfect camera
for recording your crimes.
Unlike Google, which focuses
its massive AI powers
on computational photography,
or Apple, which tries to
do a little bit of both,
Samsung has just always been
all in on sheer optical girth,
just massive and multiple
lenses grafted front and back
with conveniently pre-crushed blacks.
- That's a color correction term.
- And auto boosted sat for all your
ready-to-social criming needs.
- There you have criminals.
If you're going to crime,
you definitely use a Samsung.
But what Wilson did not know,
the phone was set to automatically
upload all photographs
to the teen victim's email account.
And with a literal photo
ID of the teen attacker
in his inbox,
well, the victim immediately
took that selfie to the police.
Wilson was swiftly arrested
and charged with robbery,
possession of stolen property,
and a controlled substance
believed to be crack cocaine.
- Oh, I'm sorry!
- Oh! Oh!
- Did you get addicted to crack?
Did somebody get addicted to crack?
- So thanks to Wilson's selfie,
justice was served.
Now, I know that this is
the least important part
of the story,
but I have to remark that Wilson
has an absolutely terrible selfie game.
I mean, just look at this travesty.
I mean, the photo is hazy,
you can see the phone's
reflection in the glasses,
and you know, why are
you wearing headphones?
♪ I fought the law ♪
♪ And the law won ♪
So honestly, six outta 10,
though bonus points for taking a photo
in front of a sign that says "Arrest".
Anyway, our next criminal
might be even dumber
because he posts a photo
of himself siphoning gas
out of a cop car.
Now, when it comes to
dealing with high gas prices,
there are many ways to
lessen the pain of the pump.
Some opt to take public transit,
others have elected to switch to electric
or hybrid vehicles.
But one Kentucky man decided to engage
in his own amateur oil exploration
by siphoning gas directly
from a police officer's car
and then brag about his crime on Facebook.
And I'm sure that you can guess
exactly how that turned out.
So in 2012, a 20 year
old Kentucky resident
Michael Baker and his girlfriend
stumbled upon an unattended
Jenkins Police vehicle,
and seizing the opportunity
for some free fuel,
Baker proceeded to siphon
gas from the squad car.
And he might have gotten away with it,
except Baker couldn't resist the urge
to have his girlfriend snap a photo
that showed him, not only stealing gas,
but also flipping the bird.
And then he memorialized it
by posting it to Facebook.
Now, there's the old proverb that goes,
"Pride cometh before the fall",
and also, "Only idiots post to Facebook."
But this cocky Kentuckian was
done in by his own vanity.
After bragging about
his crimes on Facebook,
the county issued a
warrant for Baker's arrest.
One month later,
Baker was taken into custody
and charged with misdemeanor and theft.
- Well, we was just standing there
and I thought it'd be funny take picture
and then we post it on Facebook.
- Yeah, we're sorry.
It was just a joke.
I mean, if we was gonna steal gas,
we wouldn't put it nationwide on Facebook.
I mean, we don't steal anyway, but.
- And although the
siphoning photo was removed
from his Facebook page,
Baker managed to keep
his 380 friends apprised
of his latest legal problems,
quote, "just got out of jail."
he wrote in one post.
And another post he wrote, quote,
"Yeah, lol, I went to jail over Facebook."
And in response to a friend
who had not seen the image
before it was removed,
Baker assured, quote,
"Yeah, lol, you just have to seen it.
It was funny as hell though."
- [Reporter] So I mean, do you
apologize to the cops for it?
("The Next Episode" by Dr. Dre plays)
- Not really.
- And then moving one state over,
we had the Tennessee man
who attached an Apple watch
to his girlfriend's car in
order to try to stalk her.
Now Apple markets the
Apple watch as, quote,
"The ultimate choice for a healthy life."
Now, the Apple Watch boast a variety
of health and safety
features for its users.
The Apple Watch can track your heart rate,
track your workouts,
can even be used with air tags track items
you might have misplaced,
items like your girlfriend.
Yeah, unfortunately, a
Nashville man decided
to use the Apple Watch
for nefarious purposes,
to track his girlfriends every move
and stalk her with watch's
location technology.
Now, thankfully, police
were able to intervene
before anything dire happened.
According to the March, 2022 affidavit,
Welch's girlfriend visited
the Family Service Center,
a domestic violence shelter,
to seek a restraining order against him.
Now, police officers were summoned
to the Family Safety Center
after security informed
them of Welch's presence.
But remember, tracking goes both ways.
When the police inspected
the victim's car,
they found an Apple Watch
attached to the spokes
of the car's wheel,
and they were able to
link that to the person
who was trying to track her.
But funny story,
this is actually very similar
to how I keep track of
Rene Ritchie at all times.
- [Rene] I've been using an
Apple Watch all day, every day.
- But then there's the Ohio man who sent
in a selfie of himself to police
to replace the terrible
mugshot that they took of him.
These frigging people.
Anyway, you know when most
people get a bad picture,
whether it's on a driver's license
or for a school photo,
you know, they just take the loss
and hope for a better
picture the next time around.
But Ohio man, Donald Chip Pugh,
learned the hard way
that when you're on the run from the law,
maybe that's not the best
time to contact the police
to complain about your mugshot.
- Pablo didn't know it then,
but this mugshot was gonna
cause him a lot of grief
down the line.
- Unless your goal is to assist the police
with your capture,
which, of course, is exactly what happened
in this particular case.
In 2016, Pugh was scheduled
to appear in court
for a pending DUI charge in Lima, Ohio.
And when Pugh skipped his hearing,
local police posted
the mugshot on Facebook
to solicit the public's
help in tracking him down.
Quote, "Mr. Pugh is also
currently a person of interest
in several other cases,"
including for arson and vandalism.
Now, Pugh saw his mugshot and was furious,
not that the police were
trying to track him down
or that he committed multiple crimes,
but that his picture had failed
to capture his good side.
So Pugh took the initiative.
Dressed himself up in a
houndstooth pattern suit,
not unlike the one that
I'm wearing right now,
put on some sunglasses
and texted the police,
"Here's a better photo
that one is terrible"
with an accompanying selfie.
Now, Pugh was no stranger to
the Lima Police Department,
having had previous run-ins
that included charges
of disorderly conduct,
breaking and entering,
and domestic violence.
But this was the first time
that Pugh had ever reached out
to the police while they
had an active arrest warrant
for his arrest.
Now, the Lima Police
honored Pugh's request,
uploading his new mugshot to
Facebook and writing, quote,
"We thank him for being helpful,
but now we would appreciate it
if he would come speak to us
at the LPD about his charges."
Now, a smart criminal might lay low
to avoid drawing attention to themselves,
but this video is not
about smart criminals.
And as it turns out,
Pugh was not done talking
about what he considered
to be a grave injustice
of an unflattering photo.
So after Pugh's mugshot and selfie
began circulating on the internet,
he decided to call into
Lima's classic rock station
1040.9 The Eagle,
(eagle screech)
to tell his side of the story.
Now, the local station spoke to Pugh
for its "Idiot Of The Day" segment,
and as it turns out, Pugh had the honor
of being the first idiot to
ever be interviewed on air.
- Where you at again, Chip?
- Right now?
- Yeah.
- Actually I'm sitting in a bunker
right next to Chapo Guzman.
We're trying to dig a tunnel
and get to McDonald's.
- But sadly, Pugh's run from
the law did not last very long.
The next morning, Pugh was
arrested 800 miles away
in Century Florida,
because at heart we all
knew that this Ohio man
was really a Florida man.
- In Ohio,
Northern Florida.
I mean, let's be honest,
they're really like angling for that
"weird stuff happens here".
- But ladies and gentlemen,
there is a happy ending to this story.
When Pugh was arrested in Florida,
he got to take his mugshot over again.
Though I have to admit,
I don't think that that's
much of an improvement
over his first one.
Now sometimes criminals
are incredibly stupid,
but sometimes the police are
just really, really smart.
And such was the case when the FBI
actually created a fake messaging app
and then got a whole bunch of criminals
to use the fake encrypted messaging app.
Because most of the cases
we've talked about today
involve criminals using
smartphones to tell on themselves.
But when it comes to
the more savvy criminals
who are actually trying not to
get caught committing crimes,
these folks often turn
to encrypted messaging
to cover their tracks
and shield their communications
from the prying eyes of law enforcement.
That's because when
messages are encrypted,
it's nearly impossible for law enforcement
to learn what criminal groups are doing.
So when faced with encrypted messaging,
what is law enforcement to do?
Well, simple.
Develop their own fake
encrypted messaging app,
trick criminal organizations
into downloading the fake app,
and wait for the incriminating
evidence to just roll in.
And that was the work of what was known as
Operation Trojan Shield,
a successful multi-year
electronic sting operation
led by the FBI in
conjunction with the DEA,
EUROPOL, the European Police Agency,
and law enforcement groups
from 16 other countries,
because in 2018, the FBI and
its international partners
shut down Phantom Secure,
a Canadian based company that
provided secure communications
to high level drug traffickers
in other criminal organizations.
The company would purchase smartphones,
wipe them clean of all traditional
functions like texting,
internet, and GPS,
and then it installed
encrypted email systems
that could only communicate with other
Phantom Secure phones.
And if a customer was arrested,
Phantom Secure would destroy
all data on the phone.
Now, after the feds shut
down Phantom Secure,
the CEO, Vincent Ramos, was
then indicted by a grand jury
along with his colleagues,
and would eventually plead
guilty to a raft of charges
related to drug trafficking.
And with Phantom Secure gone,
criminals were in search of a
new encrypted messaging app,
and that's where Operation
Trojan Shield comes in.
Now, at the beginning of the operation,
the FBI recruited an unnamed confidential
human source who had been
developing a next generation
secure messaging platform
for the criminal underworld
called ANOM.
Now, the app would only
work on specially modified
cell phones similar to those
created by Phantom Secure.
But what the users didn't know,
the mystery developer had engineered ANOM
to secretly forward law enforcement a copy
of every message that
was sent on the platform.
After an ANOM's launch in October 2019,
the FBI convinced a few criminals
to tell others about the phones,
and soon enough the app
caught on like wildfire.
In an 18 month period,
law enforcement provided
nearly 12,000 ANOM phones
through unsuspecting middlemen
to more than 300 criminal syndicates
in more than 100 countries.
And many of the criminals
assured each other
that the app was incredibly safe.
But rather than being safe,
police in real time could
read criminals discussing
targeted hits, drug
shipments, and other crimes,
with users making no attempt
to hide criminal plots
with code words.
And between October 2019 and June 2021,
authorities collected more
than 27 million messages
in 45 languages.
And armed with this treasure
trove of incriminating data,
the FBI and its 16 international partners
carried out raids in their
respective countries.
In a 48 hour period,
9,000 officers deployed
worldwide to make arrests
and search more than 700 locations.
According to the FBI,
more than 32 tons of drugs were seized,
killjoys,
along with 250 firearms
and 48 million in cash.
And more than 50 secret
drug labs were dismantled,
including one of the
largest clandestine labs
in German history.
In total, Operation Trojan
Shield resulted in 800 arrests,
including 500 in the 48 hour period.
And finally, I feel like I
shouldn't have to tell you this
but I'm gonna tell you this anyway,
don't live stream your crimes
because many of the people on our list
found themselves in legal trouble because
they shared evidence of
crimes after the fact.
But in the case of Tim Gionet,
better known as Baked Alaska,
this famed online provocateur
has built himself up
quite a rap sheet by
live streaming his crimes
in real time.
This idiot, Baked Alaska, is
a far-right internet troll
who openly aligned himself
with the white nationalist
griper movement,
even appearing at the infamous
2017 "Unite the right"
rally in Charlottesville.
At the time, Mr. Alaska went viral
for getting pepper sprayed while marching
with a white supremacist
in Charlottesville
as he begged people around
him to keep live streaming
as he kneeled on the ground,
milk dropping down from his face.
- I got (beeping) pepper, I need milk,
I need milk, I need milk, I need milk!
(people clamoring)
Keep streaming.
- [Cameraman] I got it.
- Keep streaming.
- [Cameraman] I am, I got it Baked.
- Keep streaming me, someone.
- [Cameraman] I'm streaming.
- [Tim] So get someone to stream me.
- I got it. I got it Baked.
- Baked Alaska's racist
advocacy in promotion
of anti-Semitic conspiracy theories
caused him to be banned
from a variety of platforms,
including Twitter,
YouTube, PayPal, and Uber.
Now, despite this, Baked Alaska's
live streaming antics only increased
and he often filmed himself
conducting all manner
of illegal things.
But it reached in apotheosis
on January 6th, 2021,
when as you know,
supporters of Donald Trump
stormed the US capital in an effort
to prevent the certification
of Joe Biden's election.
- We're storming the capital.
It's a revolution.
- And this is where Baked
Alaska's live streaming
caused himself and his allies
the most legal trouble to date.
On January 6th, Baked
Alaska began his hour-long
livestream outside the US capital
before eventually finding
himself inside the building
and interviewing participants.
- Yeah, we need to get our boy
Donald J. Trump in the office.
Yeah yeah. Can we do that real quick?
- At one point, Baked
Alaska turned to the camera
to show his face,
"We are in the capital building.
1776 will commence again."
- And despite what
looks like participation
in the coup attempt,
including shouting anti-Semitic
and Q-Anon dog whistles
while urging others to
remain in the building,
Baked Alaska told police officers
that he was a member of the media.
Court documents also state that
Baked Alaska said on camera,
"Occupy the capital, let's go.
We ain't leaving this (beep)."
You know, just your regular, everyday,
legitimate political discourse.
Now, days after the video was posted,
Baked Alaska was identified and
arrested on multiple counts,
including unlawful entry, violent entry,
and disorderly conduct on capital grounds,
but in a spectacular
selfown for the far right,
the FBI then used Baked
Alaska's livestream
to successfully arrest dozens
of rioters captured on film,
including Baked Alaska himself.
(heavily auto-tuned singing)
So the takeaway here is if
you're gonna be a racist,
treasonous, dirtbag troll
who tries to overthrow the government,
you should definitely live stream it.
Your friends are gonna love it.
- I need milk. I need milk, I need milk.
(echoing)
- So the bottom line is you should never
use your phone to document your crimes,
but you should definitely use your phone
to get delicious meals delivered straight
to your door with today's sponsor,
Hello Fresh.
Hello Fresh is a great way
to eat delicious fresh food
while still being healthy.
In fact, Hello Fresh has a whole variety
of calorie smart, carb smart, pescatarian
and veggie options.
You can customize it just how you like.
Hello Fresh delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm
to your door in less than a week,
so you can savor all the fall
flavors right from your home.
Now I'm a do-it-yourself person,
and I have to say I was
initially pretty skeptical
about Hello Fresh.
I'm a pretty good cook,
so I didn't think that I needed the help
but I actually loved it.
Even for an experienced cook,
Hello Fresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes
that I would never try on my own.
Hello, Fresh generally keeps
everyone's favorite meals,
then rotates new ones in all the time.
In fact, I usually increase the size
of my Hello Fresh serving
so I can enjoy the leftovers
for lunches.
And of course, everything was
delivered straight to my door
so I didn't have to do any shopping.
The produce actually gets to
me faster than a grocery store,
so it arrives at peak freshness and flavor
and it's also super easy to save time.
Hello Fresh cuts out the
meal planning and prep
so that recipes take only
20 to 30 minutes to cook,
literally less time to cook
than it would normally take
me to do the shopping itself.
And it's also incredibly sustainable.
Since the ingredients are preportioned,
there's less prep and food waste,
the packaging is almost entirely made
from recyclable or
already recycled content.
And Hello Fresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25% lower
than those of meals made
from store-bought groceries.
And of course, it's 72% cheaper
than dining at a restaurant.
So if you'd like to try Hello Fresh,
you can click on the link below
or go to hellofresh.com and
use the code "LEGALEAGLE65"
for 65% off, plus free shipping.
Yes, you can actually get
65% off plus free shipping
by clicking on the link that's on screen
or down in the description.
So go to hellofresh.com,
use the code "LEGALEAGLE65" or
just click on the link below,
plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
After that, click on this
playlist for more Legal Eagle
or I'll see you in court.